blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman welcome back to the david
pakman show my name is jesse dolimore
i'm subbing for david this week i'm kind
of like uh
yukon cornelius a cartoon from your
your favorite childhood christmas
special animated by some witchcraft and
brought to life
and i hold in my hand
follow-up from yesterday
yesterday i talked about a lawsuit filed
by dominion voting systems against
newsmax
oan or one america news
and patrick byrne who apparently is the
ceo of overstock.com
they're being sued for defamation in a
wide ranging multi
multi hundreds of millions of dollars
like a 1.2 billion dollar lawsuit
for defamation
in their pursuit
of election
propaganda the big lie that donald trump
didn't in fact lose
and joe biden didn't in fact win
even though they come with zero evidence
they play their weird propaganda movies
on oan
um
produced by my pillow ding dong
it is all
surreal
and in this lawsuit
this
213-page lawsuit
it really also
illuminates another issue related to the
right
and that is their dedication to
propaganda their dedication to the lies
they're they're propping up of figures
who are not of any repute
um as experts
and that is the case that i want to talk
about today and that is from january of
2021
oan put a guy on the air
promoting him as a as an expert
mathematician a professional
uh holding expertise in advanced
mathematics
when in fact spoiler alert i'll get to
it
he is not a mathematician he holds no
degrees he is in fact a convicted drug
dealer
and according to the lawsuit
a
an installer of swing sets
[Laughter]
who claimed made wild claims that some
algorithm
flipped through the election through
complex
uh
mathematical things that go way beyond
my ability i'm going to read a little
bit from this lawsuit because it is
remarkable
uh starting on page 101 if you happen to
have a copy of it or you're reading
along
on january 27 2021 oan broadcast a
segment hosted by trump campaign
affiliate christina bob
she is an oan employee
in which
she interviewed a supposed quote-unquote
expert mathematician
named ed solomon who claimed he had
uncovered mathematical evidence proving
that the november 2020 election results
were quote unquote impossible
and that therefore quote computer
software must have used an algorithm to
change the votes
end quote
must have been the case
solomon claimed that the results quote
can only have been done by an algorithm
it can't be done by humans
unquote
says the swing set installer
after he supposedly analyzed the results
in fulton county georgia
where dominion machines were used to
tabulate votes
he then claimed that the odds
all right
now listen to this this is
one dangerous scary that we were on the
brink of having an election overturned
this is serious
but it's also laughable
that an actual network
apparently all it takes to create a
network to spread propaganda and to gin
up fear and whip republicans into a
frenzy is to have a few million dollars
laying around and willing to spend them
on the creation of a tv network if you
want to call it that one america news
which is based
just a few miles down the road from
where i live in southern california
there in san diego
this is what he said
he then claimed that the odds of those
results occurring naturally were quote 1
over 10 to an exponent so large
there's not enough stars in the universe
comma
there aren't enough atoms in the
universe to explain the number
you know spoken like someone with an
advanced degree in mathematics
this is what passes for expertise in the
republican party it is disgusting it is
actually scary
moving on solomon's claims were
ludicrous oh and knew it again i'm
reading from a lawsuit here
and at a minimum recklessly disregarded
the truth oan knew solomon's claims were
false because dominion had expressly
notified oan of independent evidence
debunking them
because former president donald trump's
own administration had debunked them and
because oan itself had effectively
acknowledged it by secretly removing
several articles and broadcasts from its
own website that made similar claims
again
this is not a reputable journalistic
outlet that is not this flies in the
face of journalistic standards
there there are standard operating
procedures with journalists relative to
to correcting the record
listen
uh any endeavor that is run by human
beings is going to be fraught with the
possibility of um
incorrect information getting something
wrong
and they have rules in place
to make sure that they correct the
record that they own the mistake
deleting an article or deleting a video
because it's going to get you in legal
hot water or because it was wrong
isn't the way to do it
you note
this article has been updated to reflect
the most accurate information a previous
a previous edition of this article
contained an incorrect blah blah there's
a correction amea culpa if you will that
is not the case with oan because they
are not a journalistic outlet they are a
propaganda outlet serving the the the
the wild conspiracies of donald trump
serving at the mission and the behest of
a man who wants to tear down the fabric
of democracy in america
continuing with the lawsuit
oen also knew solomon's claims were
bogus because solomon was the farthest
thing imaginable from an expert
mathematician
he was in fact a convicted felon with no
college degree nonetheless oan broadcast
and endorsed as its own solomon's
preposterous and baseless allegations
that the 2020 election was rigged
through computer algorithms solomon
claimed were implemented in voting
machines in the very counties and
jurisdictions that used dominion
machines
now
other than the fact that this this
sentence in this lawsuit is in desperate
need of a few commas
[Laughter]
this isn't looking good
for oan this isn't looking good for
newsmax
and i'm going to get to it uh
it's not looking good for even solomon
here
dominion notified oan this is the crux
of it though they they were they were
notified by oan all of all these things
and they still continued to do what they
did for months they're still doing it in
fact dominion notified oan that solomon
was no expert mathematician and that he
was actually a convicted drug dealer who
never graduated college and whose
current job was setting up swing sets in
long island new york
at some point thereafter oen quietly
removed the videos and story from its
originally published location on its
website
but
the video remains available on oan's
rumble page and on another landing page
on its main website
again this is what passes for journalism
and this is what passes for truth
in conservative circles
the other person who is at great risk
of of a lawsuit related to all of these
bogus uh election claims
is the man himself
donald trump
been talking about the dominion lawsuit
and it looks like uh donald trump is not
going to possibly remain unscathed from
the the multi-billion dollar set of
lawsuits that have gone out
uh the insider's reporting that dominion
lawyer says the voting technology
company is still exploring
whether to sue trump over election
lies
dominion voting systems is still
weighing whether to bring a defamation
lawsuit against former president donald
trump over election conspiracy theories
an attorney for the company said tuesday
dominion continues to take an
evidence-based approach to investigating
other participants in the campaign of
lies dating all the way back to last
november attorney stephen shackleford
told insider at a press conference
the election technology company filed
three lawsuits tuesday morning against
the right-wing organizations one america
news and newsmax it has also sued two
employees of oan as well as former
overstock ceo
patrick byrne
well let me tell you it seems as though
something donald trump will be very keen
on
uh if you remember his support of
opening up our libel laws whatever that
means so we can sue journalists and make
a lot of money remember this moment
and one of the things i'm going to do
and this is only going to make it
tougher for me and i've never said this
before
but one of the things i'm going to do if
i win and i hope i do and we're
certainly leaving
is i'm going to open up our libel laws
so when they write
purposely negative and horrible and
false articles
we can sue them and win lots of money
we're going to open up those libel laws
so that when the new york times
writes a hit piece which is a total
disgrace or when the washington post
which is there for other reasons writes
a hit piece we can sue them and win
money instead of having no chance of
winning because they're totally
protected you see
with me they're not protected because
i'm not like other people but i'm not
taking money i'm not taking their money
so we're going to open up those libel
laws folks and we're going to have
people sue you like you never got sued
before
and make
a lot
of money because again
that's the that's the mission of donald
trump that's the mo that's the impetus
for donald trump's existence is to make
a lot of money
and to create general chaos in his wake
it wasn't just on the campaign trail in
2016 though that he said these things
even when he was actually president of
the united states sitting in the white
house
he was committed to
violating the united states
constitutional
the first amendment and our right to
free speech that the government shall
make no law
abridging the free press
uh remember this moment on a separate
front we are going to take a strong look
at our
country's libel laws
so that when somebody says something
that is false and defamatory
about someone that person will have
meaningful
recourse in our courts
if somebody says something that's
totally false and knowingly false
that the person that has been abused
defamed libel will have meaningful
recourse
our current libel laws are a sham
and a disgrace and do not represent
american values
or american fairness so we're going to
take a strong look at that
we want fairness
you can't say things that are false
knowingly false
and
be able to
smile as money pours into your bank
account
we're going to take a very very strong
look at that
and i think uh what the american people
want to see is fairness
so again donald trump wants to take a
strong
look at our libel laws
because you know by his own account you
can't say things that are knowingly
false you just can't do it
it would be a beautiful
poetic irony poetic justice if donald
trump was to fall under foot to be sued
for hundreds of millions of dollars
depleting any money that he actually
does have
over this after all of the bluster after
all of the nonsense about opening up the
lawyer laws
if he was to fall prey to a defamation
suit where he was found guilty
and have to pay damages
because let me tell you dominion ain't
playing around
and donald trump is at risk
here and he is justifiably at risk
because he has damaged our union
in an attempt to over overturn an
election in an attempt to overthrow the
very government under which we live
through his insurrection
his his whipping up of his his followers
into a frenzy where they wanted to
assassinate the vice president of the
united states
they erected the the hangman's gallow on
the lawn of the capital
all of these image that should stick in
your mind because it is reprehensible
behavior and if in some way
there could be some justice justice
meted out via lawsuit even a civil one
that would be good
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video welcome back
to the david pakman show i am substitute
teacher jesse dollamore
yesterday as a matter of follow-up i
talked about rand paul in a video he put
on youtube that was just filled to the
brim with anti-science propaganda
anti-mask rhetoric
um come and arrest us they can't arrest
us all he said
and uh it got him suspended got his
youtube temporarily suspended by youtube
i'm going to read from this new york
times article talking about it and then
we're going to hear
the brave
man of action rand paul's response on
twitter
youtube suspends rand paul for a week
over video disputing the effectiveness
of masks now listen
in a time the time in which we're living
through a pandemic for for going on two
years now
where we have been uh holed up in our
houses if you're taking it seriously and
and then this new norm of wearing masks
to protect one another
it is a strange time and it's the
weakest among us
morally weak ethically weak mentally
weak among us like rand paul
who insist
on pushing back against mass mandates
when the cdc has said
with with with study after study after
study that they prevent the spread they
slow the spread it's not it's not an
ultimate prevention that yes it's over
you'll never get covered if you wear a
mask
but absolutely it's a mitigation effort
reading from this new york times article
youtube on tuesday removed a video by
senator rand paul of kentucky for the
second time and suspended him from
publishing for a week after he posted a
video that disputed the effectiveness of
wearing masks to limit the spread of the
coronavirus
now if you'd like to watch the video
you can watch the full david pakman show
program
or the the isolated clip when it's
posted but i we posted and played a lot
of it
reacted to it
a youtube representative said the
republican senator's claims in the
three-minute video had violated the
company's policy on covet 19 medical
misinformation
the company policy
bans videos that spread a wide variety
of misinformation including claims that
masks do not play a role in preventing
the contraction or transmission
of covid19
we apply this is youtube we apply our
policies consistently across the
platform regardless of speaker or
political views
and we make exceptions
as in the case of my talking about it
yesterday and we make exceptions for
videos that have additional context such
as countervailing views from local
health authorities
the representative said in a statement
in the video mr paul says quote most of
the masks you get over the counter don't
work
they don't prevent infection
end quote
later in the video he adds quote trying
to shape human behavior isn't the same
as following the actual science which
tells us that cloth masks don't work end
quote
in fact
masks do work according to the near
unanimous recommendations of public
health experts
the cdc
it said in november
that wearing face masks reduced the
spread of the virus and that quote
individual benefit increases
with increasing community mass use
and a study aboard the uss theodore
roosevelt
indicated that 70 percent decrease in
transmission just from wearing masks
what is rand paul doing
to what truth
is he obligated he is supposedly
a man of science he is supposedly a
doctor
and this is the way he responded on
twitter a badge of honor
leftwing cretans at youtube
banning me for seven days for a video
that quotes two peer-reviewed articles
saying cloth masks don't work
if you want to see the band video go to
liberty tree and he promotes some
ding dong free speech website
if you'd like to see the video
i play a little bit of it and react to
it that's where you go
all of this covid misinformation is
coming on the heels
of
several governors who are banning
measures
to mitigate the spread of infection
hospitalization
and death
abbott in texas desantis in florida
all these areas across the country that
are led by ridiculous charlatan clowns
in the governor's offices
and it is good news to hear that several
local organizational efforts are being
made in in municipalities across those
states
to counteract to defy the order
of banning mass mandates reading from
the hill florida school board votes to
keep mask mandate defying desantis the
broward county school board on tuesday
voted eight to one to retain its mass
mandate for students and staff members
defying florida governor ron desantis's
executive order forcing school districts
to make masks optional
the fort lauderdale school board is
seeking legal counsel to challenge the
executive order which it claims
represents government overreach
according to wplg
quote wearing masks inside schools
regardless of vaccine status is required
to deal with the changing realities of
virus transmission
it is a necessary precaution until
children under 12 can receive a covid19
vaccination and more americans 12 and
older get vaccinated which came from ana
fusco president of the broward teachers
union it's not just florida though in
texas again there are measures in place
to defy the governor's anti-health
mandates
this is ksat the san antonio affiliate
judge delivers blow to texas governor
abbott's
ban on mandates allows san antonio to
require mass in schools
temporary restraining order allow san
antonio bexar county to impose mass
mandates
san antonio leaders scored a victory in
court against texas governor greg abbott
on tuesday in the ongoing fight over
mass mandates a bexar county civil
district court judge granted the city of
bexar county's request
for temporary restraining order against
abbott's executive order banning mass
mandates in school
again other than
fueling the culture war
what is the the impetus here
what is the goal what is the objective
in banning in in creating a system where
local municipalities listen republicans
always say this
local authorities know better than the
federal government they know what's best
for them
well why is that not the case for a
local city
to impose a mask mandate for their
community their local community
who is
is greg abbott the governor of texas who
is he to know more about what's best for
that local community
using republican logic
then the community itself
instead
they are prohibiting local
municipalities to create more stringent
rules surrounding protecting the health
and welfare of their residents
effectively the ruling allows bexar
county and san antonio officials to
issue a mass mandate in public schools
and other guidance like quarantine
protocol for now
officials say they plan to have an order
issued by the end of tuesday no details
have been released yet on the guidance
but officials will hold a live press
conference at 6 10 pm
the order was granted after an hour-long
hearing at by the 57th civil district
court with judge tony or tiago ortiaga
said an affidavit from metro health
chief medical officer dr jundo wu
weighed heavily in her decision as did
the vulnerability of children who were
returning to school amid a surge in
coronavirus cases that sentence bears
repeating weighed on her heavily on her
decision was the vulnerability of
children who are returning to school
amid a surge in coronavirus cases and
this is what is perplexing it is
baffling to me because although
republican they're still human beings
ostensibly they possess
some level of empathy unless they they
suffer from sociopathy
why don't they care about the surging
cases of coronavirus
all across
their states
this is from louisiana reading from the
insider a new orleans children's
hospital doctor says reopening schools
without masks
is a formula for disaster as covid19
rages in louisiana
this isn't just salacious use of words
in these headlines
the pandemic is raging
a year and a half in it is raging in
these areas louisiana has finally seen
an uptick in vaccinations
in the vaccination rates of its citizens
because of the fact that people look
around and they know they have family
members who are dogging they have family
members maybe multiple who are
hospitalized they're witnessing children
now
get sick
reopening schools loaded with
unvaccinated children and no mask
requirements in place is a formula for
disaster the physician chief of the
children's hospital new orleans said i
think bringing together large numbers of
children congregating them in classrooms
with masks being optional or worse yet
even forbidden
is just a formula for disaster dr mark
klein said
in an interview with cnn
it couldn't be more plainly stated
republicans have turned the culture war
uh the war on christmas and what color
coffee cup starbucks has these nonsense
arguments
they have turned it into something that
is deadly
it's one thing if you want to whine
about the the national anthem and
someone silently kneeling in protest and
you want to turn that into a culture war
it's another thing entirely when you
endanger the lives of children
innocent babies
who are
have no other choice but to be protected
they cannot do it themselves
we're not horses or goats or cows
that get squirted out and immediately
are on our feet walking around eating
grass that's not how it works with human
beings
i'm sad to say republicans
we need nurturing
and protection
for a great deal of time before we're
capable of doing it ourselves
and greg abbott and ron desantis are
getting in the way of that
they're making a choice
to force
municipalities into a situation where
they're either violating the law
or making sure their kids are safe
unconscionable
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
i am jesse dollamore sitting in for
david while he is on vacation uh hey
listen if you've been enjoying
the the look of my stupid face and the
sound of my dumb voice
i would encourage you to click the links
in the top of the description there and
uh check out where you can find me on
social media and on youtube
you know one of the
the the major drawbacks of the
political divide that has largely been
created by donald trump at his camp is
the fact that
truth is no longer truth science is no
longer respected that kind of has been
the case with the republican party for a
long time
but it has really hit a fever pitch
under donald trump and this new
fascistic version of the republican
party
and in part of that is
obviously vaccine hesitancy which is
born out of a contempt
for expertise and a contempt
for science
they mock the educated they they are
they are
pleased as punch to be
the poorly educated remember when donald
trump said that on the campaign trail i
love
we love the poorly educated we won the
evangelicals we won with young
we won with old
we won with highly educated we won with
poorly educated i love the poorly
educated
and one of the the downfalls of america
being such a touchstone culturally
across the globe is the fact that our
idiots
uh
our idiots uh are contagious and they it
leads to vaccine hesitancy and
anti-science views
even outside of the the borders of the
united states
enter the story from reuters which is
tragic
and scary
suspected saline switch sparks vaccine
stir
in germany
authorities in northern germany appealed
to thousands of people on tuesday
to get another shot of covid 19 vaccine
after a police investigation found that
a red cross nurse
may have injected them with a saline
solution
in place of
a covet vaccine
adding to the hysteria and the fear here
is that this nurse is suspected of
injecting salt solution into people's
arms instead of genuine doses at a
vaccine center in friesland a rural
district near the north sea coast in the
early spring
and the early spring is the element of
this that is really a bummer because
that was when
the elderly on mass were getting
vaccinated to go back and start living
their lives with far less trepidation
and worry that they might catch the
disease
and be hospitalized or die quote i'm
totally shocked by this episode end
quote sven ambrosi a local counselor
said on facebook as local authorities
issued the call to around 8
600 residents who may have been affected
while saline solution is harmless most
people who got vaccinated in germany in
march and april when the suspected
switch took place are elderly people at
high risk of catching the potentially
fatal viral disease
the motive of the nurse who was not
named was not clear but she had aired
skeptical views about vaccines and
social media posts police investigators
said
it was not immediately clear whether the
suspect had been arrested or charged in
the case which according to broadcaster
ndr has been handed to a special unit
that investigates politically
motivated
crimes
that
is sad
that health care
that a
a a a a a vaccine with
proven efficacy
has been turned into some kind of
political football
among conspiracy theorists
and chaos stirrers
as it is in the case of the american
political system
this isn't a political issue
this is a global health crisis the likes
of which we haven't seen for 100 years
and because of
idiots who want to maintain political
power
culture warriors
things like this are happening
this could be laid directly at the feet
of the republican party even though it's
foreign
in another
vaccine-related
occurrence
you know it's
[Laughter]
it is a strange thing to me that there
are certain people who just love to be
owned
and and peter ducey the dingus over at
fox news who is now their white house
correspondent which used to be
a a lofty position something you would
strive for because it meant you were at
the top of your game instead nepotism
junior over there at fox news
he's the he's the correspondent well
yesterday at the briefing
it was uh sunday sunday sunday it's like
a monster truck rally with peter ducey
just getting smashed
by jen saki
this moment transpired and buckle up
because it is
president tries to reach unvaccinated
americans has there been any thought
given looking back to the possibility
that he may have created
some vaccine hesitancy when last year
around this time the previous
administration
was rushing to get a vaccine authorized
and the now president said i trust
vaccines i trust scientists but i don't
trust donald trump and at this moment
the american people can't either
well i think it's safe to say he still
doesn't trust donald trump so that
hasn't changed but he does trust
scientists he does trust data experts
and he does trust the people leading the
cdc the fda
which is the gold standard of approval
for vaccines i'd also note because this
question often comes up that the
president has repeatedly given credit to
scientists and experts from the prior
administration even as recently as just
a few weeks ago for their role in moving
the vaccine forward yes but at the time
when donald trump is out there saying
we're going to have a vaccine in the
next couple weeks next couple months
and joe biden is out on the campaign
trail saying don't trust donald trump
did that create any kind of vaccine
hesitancy
not that we've seen in the data i would
note that at the time just for context
the former president was also suggesting
people inject versions of poison into
their veins to cure covet so i think
that's a relevant point and joe biden
then vice president was saying we gotta
wait until something is fully authorized
and it's still not
well the fda works on the timeline and
of science at the same time we've also
seen tens of millions of people's lives
saved who have gotten the vaccine that
data is clear across the country go
ahead so peter ducey
is accusing joe biden
of creating vaccine hesitancy in the
united states
[Laughter]
oh
come on man
this is an unbelievable thing and by the
way a great off-the-cuff moment for
jinsaki to mention no no no no no you're
not going to do this your guy
your guy that you're fighting to defend
right now is the guy who remember and
i'm going to play the clip because
it is one of those moments that we
should never forget it it's another one
of those moments that we should cherish
that we're not living in that era
anymore the era of donald trump when he
did absolutely unequivocally suggests
that people
that it could be uh
a workable solution to fight the virus
if we were to inject disinfectant into
our bodies supposing we hit the body
with a tremendous uh whether it's
ultraviolet or just very powerful light
and i think you said
that hasn't been checked but you're
going to test it
and then i said supposing you brought
the light inside the body you can which
you can do either through the skin or
in some other way
and i think you said you're going to
test that too sounds interesting
right and then i see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out
in a minute
one minute and is there a way we can do
something like that
by
injection inside or
or
almost a cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number of lungs so it'd be
interesting to check that so that you're
gonna have to use
medical doctors with but it sounds
it sounds interesting to me so just
remember that
don't let
sidetracking questions from idiots like
peter ducey distract you
from the fact that one we have a
competent
empathetic
decent man as president of the united
states now now not
not a dingus who who
dangerously suggests that disinfectant
could cure the virus inside the body
i mean there is something to rejoice
about is there not
in other covid related news
there are states out there
who aren't relying on the goodwill of
people with no good will to get
vaccinated
we're seeing spikes in all across the
country louisiana and arkansas florida
texas where we thought we were we had a
stranglehold on this thing we thought
the the worst days were behind us and
florida's infection rate right now is
approaching the highest levels of the
entire pandemic
child hospitalization rates are raising
it is it is a worrying specter
all across the country but in certain
states it's worse
in my home state of california
not my home state but where i live right
now
they are taking action they are
mandating now it was just just announced
they are mandating
vaccines for health care workers reading
from the la times california healthcare
workers must be vaccinated by end of
september under new health order in what
officials characterized as the first
requirement of its kind in the nation
california ordered thursday that health
care workers statewide must be fully
vaccinated against covet 19 come early
fall
the new mandate applies to employees and
hospitals skilled nursing facilities
clinics doctor's offices hospice
facilities dialysis centers and most
other health care settings and
stipulates that they complete their
inoculation regimen by september 30th a
quote here from an official as we
continue to see an increase in cases and
hospitalizations due to the delta
variant of covet 19 it's important that
we protect the vulnerable patients in
these settings
dr tomas aragon state public health
officer and director of the california
department of public health said in a
statement today's action will also
ensure that health care workers
protected
vaccines are how we end this pandemic
reasonable this is a reasonable approach
an expected approach which is miles
apart
it is
an alternate universe here in california
leadership wise relative to
florida
or arkansas i know the farron cousins
talked about it the other day about asa
hutchinson the former senator and now
governor
of arkansas who's like oh
i made a huge mistake y'all
i shouldn't have signed the ban on mask
mandates
because now people are dying all around
me all my constituents are in a in bad
shape
states like that
rules like that don't apply in certain
states california being one of them
it was just last week that governor
gavin newsom announced that california
healthcare employees would soon either
have to show proof of their vaccination
status or be subjected to regular
testing
the new order largely removes the
testing option and allows only limited
religious or medical exemptions from the
vaccine requirement employees who are
exempted would have to be tested
regularly twice a week if they work in
acute or long-term care facilities and
once a week in other healthcare settings
unvaccinated employees would also have
to wear a surgical mask or respirator
such as an n95 while inside a facility
all of these are reasonable expectations
of the entire populace
but of course they're reasonable for
someone working in a healthcare setting
it is
disgraceful
the manner with which certain
municipalities certain states
have dealt with this
which is to say not dealing with it
to to act like this is a liberty issue
is nonsense
as i've talked about
if you choose not to wear a seat belt
you're only harming yourself
if you choose not to wear a helmet on a
motorcycle
really it's it's just you
that you're gonna harm
this is not the case with the
coronavirus
if if i'm not vaccinated i am and i have
been for months but if i'm not and i'm
walking around asymptomatic just
breathing my filth all over everybody
and i get somebody sick and they die
that's on me
it's not about my liberty when i infect
someone and they die and i've encroached
upon their rights
it's not wearing a helmet it's not
wearing a seat belt it's not mo
liberty y'all
has nothing to do with that
it is basic
decency and the protection of our
neighbors
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show welcome back to the
david pakman show my name is jesse
dollamore and i would ask that uh if
you've been enjoying me uh guests
hosting for david over the past last
couple days the uh check me out i'm at
dollarmore that's on youtube and twitter
and uh the rest of them anyway thanks a
lot
so
mike lindell the the my pillow guy his
symposium has been going on the last
couple days and it has been
a mess
from the very start
starting with the delay because they
were hacked
because you know he's got so much
incredible
uh critical information for the american
public that people need to hack to get
him off off the rails
well today was no different
in fact i got a couple clips here to
share that really just they give you a
flavor for the nonsense and for the
the the chaos
that anything involving mike pillow
brings
here's the first clip of an absolute
expected moment
where they're blaming technical problems
of course on conspiracy it's quite
coincidental that the video feed breaks
and the live streaming platforms break
as soon as we start talking about this
that my friends is a man named ron
watkins
ron watkins who is thought by many to be
q
who ran 8 chan or one of those other
conspiratorial hate websites
and uh he is is all been admitted on an
hbo's uh documentary that he's cue
that's the kind of uh
character and caliber of individual that
mike pillow
mike lindell has at this cyber symposium
to uncover the truth of donald trump's
win in the 2020 election
that's not all though
get this speaker
it really is just emblematic it sums
everything up in the trump era exactly
how far down the rabbit hole people have
gone with their disrespect for expertise
their disregard
for
truth and journalism and
everything that we should hold true in a
free society watch this ladies and
gentlemen i'm not a computer guy
i don't know
what most of this stuff means but i've
been researching this election since
november 3rd
and i can tell you right now that
everything we're seeing right here we
saw in antrim county the adjudication
logs being deleted
it was absolutely censored by the media
most people don't know that this isn't
anything new
we've seen it in antrim county we've now
seen it in maricopa county and we're now
looking at it with our very own eyes in
colorado
what is colorado matter why are they
attacking colorado we need to wake up as
people and you the cameras in the back
there not all of you but the cnns of the
world you guys need to start reporting
this and stop fact checking it
and the crowd
goes wild the small yet present crowd
did you catch some of those things that
should frighten you it should amuse you
but it also is there's an element of
cringe there that goes beyond just
that guy's a dumbass
uh for one
he admits i'm not a computer guy
i don't understand a lot of this stuff
but
i'm going to offer my unfettered opinion
as though it's qualified and then spouts
a series of debunked conspiracy theories
that have been led by
the charge of have been led by mike
lindell and donald trump and lynn wood
and
the rest of these purveyors of
conspiracy and propaganda
and then that last comment
should give you pause
start reporting
and stop fact checking
[Laughter]
stop reporting but or start reporting
but please
please
stop with your infernal fact checking
it's getting in the way of our
propaganda
unbelievable
these are the times we live in right now
if you thought it couldn't get any worse
while donald trump with president it has
absolutely the the the train has jumped
the track
the trump train
has has has veered it's careened into a
wall and now it is just in shambles
it is a pile of twisted metal and
carnage
and this is what we got
so in related news
to the the the death of expertise the
disregard for science and data and
research is that the fact that the
international governmental panel on
climate change
released its long-awaited report just
the other day
and before i get to some of the key
findings that i find interesting and
alarming i want to talk about an aspect
of american culture that exists within
evangelical christianity
there's this pastor named perry stone
and we're going to get to a clip of him
but
coming from this faith tradition i was
raised an evangelical christian a
conservative christian nationalist if
you will
and
when i was when i was coming up in the
church it was
it was
taught that god gave man dominion over
the earth and because of that we needed
to be good stewards
of god's creation the planet
and it doesn't seem to be that way
anymore
perry stone here who isn't some no-name
you may not know who he is but he's got
a youtube channel of like 650 000 people
he's the leader of a congregation people
listen to him they look up to him they
admire him
they honor him with leadership
and he is saying in this clip i'm
getting ready to play
screw it
let it burn
yeah
climate change real but we don't care
because jesus is coming back in
revelation chapter 20 when christ comes
back to earth and sets up his kingdom
he's going to change everything and
there's going to be a thousand years of
peace and so the sons of god and these
are the children of god these are
believers who return with christ who set
up the kingdom for a thousand years
we're going to see a complete change in
the earth and that what we call the
travail of creation or the travel of the
earth will cease when the messiah
returns so those who criticize believers
now for not being you know
environmentally concerned or whatever we
know how the book ends we know where
this is going we know how in the end
when messiah comes back look folk can i
say something to you and say it in love
it's wonderful to do all that we can to
help the planet but at the same time if
you know what the prophecy says you know
what's coming and you know
that real peace real joy and and
everything that men want will only
happen with the return of the messiah
and you can see that all through the
book of zechariah you can see it in the
writings of isaiah and that messiah
without a doubt is one man and it's
jesus christ that is alarming
that is an admission that yeah listen a
lot of christians we just don't care
about it because we're waiting for jesus
our faith
is
paramount to anything else
we're gambling on the fact that jesus is
going to be coming back to save us
so let it burn
that is that is a remarkable admission
that i believe is held by millions of
people
and it is
very difficult
to pry that viewpoint away from people
when when it is not substantiated by
fact
when it is only an emotional response
to
what is happening in our world
and let's talk a little bit about what's
happening in our world specifically some
of the key findings of the ipcc report
one
is that
humans are to blame
for for climate change without a doubt
we are in a situation now where it
cannot be denied
reading from this article from reuters
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change the ipcc used its strongest terms
yet to assert that humans are causing
climate change
with the first line of its report
summary reading quote it is unequivocal
that human influence has warmed the
atmosphere ocean
and land
it is unequivocal
the stark language marked a shift from
previous ipcc reports which had said it
was extremely likely that industrial
activity was to blame
there is no uncertainty language in this
sentence because there is no uncertainty
that global warming is caused by human
activity and the burning of fossil fuels
that was the the ipcc co-author
um frederick otto he's a climatologist
at the university of oxford
these are learned individuals
they are well versed in climatology
they're not
making wild claims like a mike lindell
with zero expertise
these people have dedicated their lives
to one single topic
to get it right
to be an expert
not to be fueled by dunning kruger mania
another key takeaway
is that uh the temperatures are going to
continue to rise
even the severest of cuts are unlikely
to prevent global warming of 1.5 degrees
celsius over pre-industrial temperatures
without immediate steep emissions cuts
though average temperatures could cruise
past 2 degrees celsius by the end
of the century
is scary
and it may seem like a long ways away
the end of the century
but
if you're getting ready to have a kid
they could very well be alive then
we're talking about
protecting the climate and the planet
for posterity's sake
this is a literal
existential crisis that we're facing
what's the saying about uh it's an
honorable man who plants a tree the
shade of which he'll never enjoy
i'm sure i botched it but it's something
like that
and are we gonna be
the perry stones of the world or are we
gonna plant trees the shade of which
we'll never enjoy
another
key finding here is one that we all are
witnessing in real time
and that that is that extreme weather
events are getting more and more common
and more
and more extreme
they can tie this to what's called
attribution science it's no longer
guessing whether or not uh climate
change is is the responsibility is the
the triggering factor for the wildfires
here in california or in australia or
anywhere else around the world
it's no longer up in the air whether
flooding events
are caused
by
the climate change they know now
attribution science
that's something you should familiarize
yourself with
in the past people would say you can't
say anything about any individual event
said ipcc co-author michael wayner a
climate scientist at the lawrence
berkeley national laboratory in
california
but now we can actually make
quantitative statements about extreme
weather events
this is serious
now listen the report does say
that where we if we were to to stop it
that some of these changes are going to
happen whether we we could go to zero
carbon emission right now and some of
these changes are still going to take
place but they're saying it's not too
late
this is an extreme problem i believe
it's going to take extreme measures
to get it under control
whether that be the new green new deal
whether that be some of the the
initiatives that biden has proposed
but it's gonna take more than just
letting it burn because of jesus
that is a fact
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman